wir sind hier in einem public supermarkt
in das will in kleider in südflorida und
und hier ja hier sieht man wie einfach
das eigentlich geht hier auf der einen
seite die die supermarktregale hier
käsesorten um den hintergrund sieht man
irgend sieht man wie die menschen
geimpft werden das geht ganz einfach man
geht hin man registriert sich zuerst
online habe jetzt dann auf einen sessel
gesetzt die identität überprüft und dann
geht es auch schon los spritze in den in
den arm und 15 minuten am sessel und
dann geht es weiter
einige der einige der senioren die
hierher gekommen sind haben haben dann
auch noch in sachen eingekauft und alle
sind natürlich sehr happy geht ganz
einfach hier eigentlich
das sind für mich sehr improvisiert aus
wie reagieren denn die amerikaner darauf
plötzlich einfach so zwischen den
regalen im supermarkt geimpft zu werden
muss ein bisschen anders ist hier in den
usa ist dass jeder supermarkt praktisch
auch eine eigene apotheke gehabt so wir
sehen ist dass so eine kleine einheit
die mitten im supermarkt eingebettet ist
so gesehen ist das hier hinter mir eine
ganz professionelle operation die
einfach nur medizinischen zwecken dienen
neben der ausgabe von medikamenten in
diesem fall von impfstoffen und was gut
ist die amerikaner sind es gewöhnt
viele der impfungen auch gegen die
grippe eben in solchen supermärkte eben
in sollten apotheken eigentlich zu
bekommen und darum ist diese aktion hier
wirklich sehr populär und sehr
erfolgreich